johann montana will vamp left-handed
switch heading third baseman
beautiful pitch low fastball
right at the knees two down
here's jose abreu
the right-handed hitting first baseman
swung out and miss he struck him out
with a pitch that the bottom just fell
out of it
nice slider from black he strikes out a
pair
lucas giolito
second start of the year he got banged
around in their season opener against
minnesota
but the indians didn't face anybody that
pitched better last year than lucas
giallito
she leads 2-2
strict recall bring him up on an inside
fastball at 95 miles an hour one away
full count pitch to ramirez
swing and a miss strike three 96 miles
an hour
and two strikeouts start the game here
for the indians in carlos santana the
switch hitting first baseman will swing
it left handed
he smashes that one by giolito and into
center field the indians have their
first hit
[Applause]
lead off manafort here in the second
round
and three balls two strikes on franmio
reyes the very dangerous power hitter
strike three
he floated one in yeah changeable gets
you strikeout
and he struck him out with another good
slider
third k for police act one down here in
the third inning leori garcia will
switch
left-handed
larry to left field that's down there
you go no more perfect game no more no
hitter
because they create so much spin that
was a nice piece of hitting by tim
anderson that's how you lead the majors
in hitting garcia is going to try to go
to third there's a throw it's in time
but ramirez can't come up with the ball
that's unbelievable he was dead to
rights
now the 2-2 2-2 for beau taylor and
strike three lucas elevates an off-speed
pitch
and four strikeouts from giolito here
comes police
0-2 delivery
swung on it missed strike three got him
to chase a change up low and outside
back-to-back strikeouts for police act
and he struck him out
seven k's for pleisek he strikes out the
side here in the fourth inning this
young man is on fire
and there's a ball ripped down the right
field line
on his way to third goes hernandez
ramirez gives a look he'll hold with a
single and the indians have them at the
corners here in the fourth well jose was
sitting on that changeup did you see him
keep the hands back andre on that one he
left to change up upstairs he drilled it
down into the right field corner
here's the o2
high fastball not his tempo one gone
that was exactly what he was trying to
do on the o2 pitch after a straight
change he got it there and he got the
strikeout he was looking for
now the 3-2 pitch from gleason
fastball right back to him what a play
by poisak
oh my goodness you talk about cat-like
reflexes
beautiful play way to field your
position right there
i didn't think he had a chance at it
[Applause]
on the one-two
slowed it down and struck him out with a
beautiful off-speed pitch
here comes the o2 to santana
swing at a missed rank three side
retired in order and we'll head to the
six
here comes the o2 pitch
swung on in this hay struck him out on
three pitches and anderson split his bat
in half
there you go he felt like he should have
hit it but as
he's just adding to his career high now
nine strikeouts
the line in the pitch and it's swung on
bounced toward first diving toward the
line to grab it abreu on his knees slaps
the bag with his glove heck of a play by
abrayu
as money grand all will be the lead off
hitter the o2 pitch
swing and a miss chased the change up
down and away career best 10 strikeouts
for zach
garcia they hit her
the pitch
and strike three called on a fastball
garcia tried to guess something off
speed
and he guessed wrong
a career-best 11 strikeouts now for
policing
career high and homer's last year for
grand all
two and one
yasmania drive to right field on a line
santana makes the catch off the double
clutch tim scores and the sox have the
first run of the ball game with one out
in the night now the 1-1 pitch
eloy long fly ball center field mercado
back and he makes the catch sox will get
another run monkatta scores and it's two
nothing sucks
tuna
robert up the middle into center field
that's a base hit
abreu scores golan's on his way home it
is four-nothing socks luis robert
straight up the middle he got a bash in
the head from santana and he'll take the
two runs thank you
bases loaded and the tying run coming to
the plate
one ball no strikes
on the ground tim anderson to first and
that will do it
with a stretch from jose abreu and a
lengthy bottom nine